vivir en afganistán no es fácil ni
siquiera para los hombres y si eres
mujer el reto es aún mayor
ser mujer bajo el régimen talibán
significa que no eres parte de la
sociedad te quedas en casa haciendo nada
ellos piensan que no eres importante que
no puedes hacer nada para el futuro para
el país ellos quieren a la gente matan a
todos y ser mujer discapacitada en
afganistán es aún más duro no es nada
fácil
yo soy mi lofar bayat capitana del
equipo de silla de ruedas de basket de
afganistán llegué a españa hace tres
días y ahora estoy en bilbao
empecé a pedirle a mis amigas que me
ayuden a preguntarle a españa si por
favor me podían ayudar y evitar que el
talibán me mate porque he salido en
muchos vídeos hablando de ellos por todo
lo que hice en el basket y porque
trabaje por los derechos de la mujer en
afganistán y esos son motivos
suficientes para que me maten
fueron días difíciles muy malos entrar
al aeropuerto de kabul no fue fácil era
muy peligroso y muy duro para todos
habían muchos talibanes y no nos dejaban
entrar disparaban nos golpeaban de hecho
a ramesh ya mí nos golpearon y yo tenía
mucho miedo
en ese momento yo estaba llorando ramesh
me decía sé fuerte estoy contigo estoy
aquí y nunca te dejaré sola yo le dije
mira qué peligrosos son y qué mal las
personas son es prácticamente imposible
contener las lágrimas de acné nunca
imaginamos que un día el talibán tomaría
control de kabul nunca pensamos que
nuestras vidas cambiarían así que
tendríamos que abandonar nuestro país
amo este país porque tiene gente hermosa
son muy buenos estoy agradecida con toda
la gente que nos ha apoyado que nos ha
ayudado y con el gobierno por traernos
de manera segura ramesh y yo esperamos
que pueda retomar el básket muy pronto